10 la crise latente aura été longue et
le retour au canada parsemé d'embûches
après 15 ans derrière les barreaux
joseph à la terre est finalement de
retour en sol canadien
bros visiblement ému il raconte une
détention difficiles marquées par de
mauvais traitements imaginez un surf and
very deep ocean
c'était comme être sous l'eau pendant 15
ans et ne pas pouvoir respirer j'ai dit
il le calvaire de joseph à la terre a
commencé en 2007 l'egypte au canadien
alors âgé de 31 ans s'envole vers le
caire pour rendre visite à sa famille
dès son arrivée à l'aéroport il est
arrêté par les autorités égyptiennes qui
l'accusent d'être un espion à la solde
d'israël
un procès expéditif et ultra médiatisé
joseph à la terre clame son innocence et
soutient que les autorités égyptiennes
ont obtenu ces aveux sous la torture
jackson rodriguez et l'égypte au
canadien sera finalement condamnée à 15
ans de détention qui purgera dans la
prison de tora reconnu pour ses services
malheureusement la torture et est très
très commune en plus d'être accusés
d'espionnage joseph al attar et est
susceptible de subir des persécutions
pour sa conversion au catholicisme et
pour son orientation sexuelle ces trois
épisodes réunis à en prison on avait
toutes les raisons de croire qu'ils
subissaient de très mauvais traitements
et donc de la torture
pendant sa longue détention des
défenseurs des droits de l'homme
reprocher à ottawa de ne pas en faire
assez pour obtenir sa libération
maintenant de retour au pays joseph ne
veut pas au gouvernement et ne demande
qu à rebâtir sa vie au canada le modjo
plusieurs questions persistent sur le
rôle qu'ottawa a joué dans le retour au
pays de joseph attar dans un tweet la
ministre des affaires étrangères mélanie
joly s'est réjoui de la libération de
l'egypte aux canadiens et à remercier
ses diplomates pour leur travail acharné
dans ce dossier ici est nommé dire adieu
au canada toronto